part one of the finale airs tonight on
NBC and you know this whole season
really has been a hard dose of reality
for Alicia Keys who opened up to et
online so ficha lacy my heart is like a
part of this whole thing you told me
before you gets like you quit every two
I do a quit every Tuesday telling them
quitting this enter this show is
terrible because Tuesday's obviously
result the results show as a first-time
coach she's been on an emotional roller
coaster the ride ends tomorrow night
when Alicia and way McDonald her one
artist remaining Duke it out in the
finals with the longtime pros Adam has
two singers left and Blake has one and
she admits it's been a learning curve to
take the guys on well tell me what
you've learned this season that you're
gonna apply next season the most
interesting thing to learn is who is
watching the show that's how you choose
song choices that's how you make great
choices for how is it gonna resonate
with the people watching I've also
learned that just like in life you don't
know what the outcome is gonna be
and so you really have to go with your
heart the 35 year old Grammy winner also
learned a lot about her fellow coaches
Adam I thought I totally wasn't gonna
like even though he's a good friend of
mine like in the sense of the
competition of this thing cuz he's super
competitive actually very competitive I
know how to win the show I've won three
times I definitely didn't know I was
gonna like Blake as much as I do
I didn't realize he's gonna be just so
funny oh she did I just frickin love
Miley so much I love that she calls you
big sis yesterday as my that's my little
sis and I'm her big sis and we are
working naked and while it's been fun
it's still a competition and this
first-timer ones bragging right when she
comes back next season that's when Gwen
Stefani returns to take Miley seat so
sorry
when's a good friend I'm so excited to
be doing a show with her cuz it's like
this two women thing is like the right
thing for this show they can't ever go
back
you